[Music]
hey you guys welcome back again to my
tomes of terror this is my little book
review show
now the book that i'm going to be
talking about today was one that i
actually read probably back in the early
2000s and i really really loved it
and when i was initially thinking about
doing this series this was definitely
one that i wanted to do a reread on to
see if i liked it as much the second
time and i absolutely did and to be
honest with you
reading all the reviews of this on
goodreads
uh this seems to be in a lot of people's
favorite books of whole of all time uh
lists and i can totally totally see why
this is boy's life by robert r mccammon
now i don't think
that this was actually the first
mccammon that i read because he's
generally he was generally known as a
horror writer and this isn't exactly a
horror novel but i had read a few of his
other uh stuff before before i got to
this one because i saw this one was
recommended a lot now this book first
came out in 1991
and i believe that it won the world
fantasy award
uh in 1992 and is pretty much almost
universally considered among his fans
and among critics and stuff like that as
his best work
now as i mentioned it's not
really a horror novel per se it does
have horror elements in it it does have
kind of scary elements in it
honestly i'm not entirely sure
what genre you would call this um it's
kind of a patchwork of a lot of
different things i think first and
foremost primarily it's a coming-of-age
type of story
uh it's also got a murder mystery kind
of like woven in there it's has some
like southern gothic elements and it
also has a lot of
magical realism type elements so i think
um when i looked on the wikipedia page
uh it made me call i think it called the
genre like mystery dark fantasy i don't
know if i'd go as far as dark fantasy
because dark fantasy kind of more
conjures up at least in my mind i don't
know just like more supernatural
elements this is kind of more akin to
i see this compared to ray bradbury's
stuff a lot uh which is totally that's a
totally legitimate comparison
particularly is something wicked this
way comes or dandelion wine or something
like that um i've seen it compared a lot
to stephen king's the body uh which
stand by me was based on also a
completely legitimate comparison where
it's just kind of like
um you know a coming-of-age story and
kind of like a quilt of life occurrences
with this one thread kind of going
through the middle of it and it's sort
of like so it's sort of like kind of a
nostalgic magic of childhood type stuff
too but it's also got like some scary
elements and a little bit of
supernatural stuff going on
so this book is
i'm not sure if i'm sure this has a lot
of uh of aspects of mccammon's own
upbringing because this is actually
about a 12 year old boy named corey
mackinson
and he's growing up uh in
a small town in alabama now robert
mccammon also grew up in a small town in
alabama so i imagine that a lot of his
own childhood experiences
um
you know informed his writing of this
novel so one of the themes of the novel
is kind of like the magic of childhood
and how you know certain things when
you're a kid seem
uh so much more magical whimsical and
also horrible and monstrous
um and i think the kind of the theme of
the book is to not let go of that as you
become an adult because that's something
that comes up um a lot and comes up in a
lot of characters in the book how you
know people
when they grow up they have to let go of
all this magic that they had when they
were children and how you should really
try to retain that into adulthood and uh
you know much like like i said like ray
bradbury's work or some of stephen
king's stuff it was particularly stuff
that was set in the 60s maybe even like
the first part of it uh you know stuff
like that but really it gives me the
strong the body vibes really because
it's just kind of like you know a group
of young boys uh you know doing young
boy things and like kind of talking
about life and what it was like to be a
kid growing up in that era like in that
uh in that location so
the plot of the novel it's again it's
kind of hard to
pin down because it has a plot it has a
through line there is like a murder
mystery that's sort of
wending its way through uh this through
the book
but
this story it's almost
reads like so don't go into this
expecting this to be like a a
traditional narrative i guess
what it is is it's set uh over about the
course of a year and it's set in four
sections which each represent a season
and you're essentially following it's in
the first person and it's from uh the
point of view of this 12 year old boy
corey
and he's just kind of going through his
life and he goes on
all of these sort of tangents are like
kind of adventures i guess some of which
are kind of cool some of which are scary
and life-threatening uh some of which
are very sad and tragic but all coming
back toward like this central murder
mystery so it's almost kind of like the
murder mystery part is like a river and
then like all this other stuff is like
tributaries that kind of like go off and
some of them just kind of go off but a
lot of them just kind of come back and
feed into the river i guess if you want
to put it like that um as i said i read
some other reviews of this most people
are just effusive in their praise four
and five stars all over the place every
now and then you did get one that was
just one or two stars that say hey i was
interested in the murder mystery why
does it go off on all these seemingly
unrelated tangents but i think as i said
the whole point of the book is just
trying to give you this patchwork of
childhood at this time period this
patchwork of this small town at this
time and you know the the murder mystery
being sort of just like the the largest
or emblematic of sort of the dark side
of small town life in the 1960s i guess
if you want to put it like that so it
almost reads i don't want to it's not
exactly like
a series of short stories because it is
you know following a timeline and it is
referring back to other things but it is
very um episodic in the sense that
some things you know each chapter is
kind of i don't want to say it's
completely self-contained because as i
said it does refer back to other things
but it's almost like a series of
interconnected short stories or
interconnected vignettes uh some of
which do come back around and feed into
the central narrative you know so if you
go into it knowing that and not
expecting it to be
you know focused on this murder mystery
the whole time then i think you'll find
it a really really enriching like a
really rewarding experience a lot of
people and this is actually one of the
few books that i've read
that
really does give you a sense and even
though uh you know this the kid is
growing up like before i was born
it really does give you a sense of
what it would have been like uh day to
day to be a child in that era you know
what i mean and in that uh in that
particular location in a very small town
in the south and it really captures that
um that kind of thing of being a kid
where everything is just like the world
is just so magical and like your
imagination and reality kind of like
meld together in a way that's you know
that you can't really tease apart and i
really think that it's really really
good at capturing that i mean mccammon
is a great writer um as i said i've read
some of his other stuff as well i mean
anything if you like like stephen king's
stuff like the body or you know or it
you know particularly the first part of
it with about the kids if you like ray
bradbury's stuff uh then you'd probably
be really into this too i've also seen
this compared to to kill a mockingbird
uh which you know it kind of has that
sort of vibe about it as well because it
does have a lot of stuff about
you know it's alabama in 1964. there's a
lot of stuff about uh you know the
burgeoning civil rights movement there's
a lot of stuff about you know people in
the town being in the clan and stuff
like that so it goes into as i said it
goes into like awesome stuff about being
a kid you know riding your bike through
the fields and going to the monster
movies and all that kind of stuff and it
really captures that really well but it
captures like kind of the dark
underbelly as well and also kind of
captures uh these sort of
crazy
like eccentric sort of characters so in
that way it's kind of like a southern
gothic uh a lot you know the way that a
lot of the characters are scribed so
kind of like if you like the way michael
mcdowell like has these kind of real
eccentric southern characters that's
kind of turns up in here too so in other
ways it's not really like a michael
mcdowell but it does have that kind of
southern like alabama type of flavor to
it so if you're into that then you might
like this one as well uh as i said it's
long it's probably like six seven
hundred pages something like that um i
the first time i read it as i said i
think i read it back in 2001 2002
something like that and maybe a little
bit later and i think i checked it out
of the library like the print version
but i was very very happy to see when i
was looking through my kindle unlimited
if you have kindle unlimited you can
actually read it online for free which i
did uh so i was really really happy to
see that that was on there because i
really particularly wanted to reread
this so as i said we're following a 12
year old boy named uh corey now at the
very very beginning of the story his dad
is a milkman
and corey always gets up early like
before he goes to school and he helps
his dad out on his milk route in this
small town called zephyr in alabama
which i don't think is a real town
so on this particular morning it's very
cold i believe it's in march
so they're out before the dawn and
they're delivering the milk to everybody
in the town that ordered some
and while they're on this sort of county
right i think it's uh route 10 or
whatever
uh they're very startled as they're
driving down the down the road in the
milk truck this car comes
barreling out of the woods
and goes into a lake and starts to sink
so corey's dad whose name is tom um
obviously jumps out of the truck and
jumps in there to help the person like
trying to get because they can see that
there's a driver in the car uh so that
he so he jumps in there and tries to
help them out
however when he gets in there and
attempts to get this person out of the
car he notices a few very alarming
things
one uh this man is completely naked
two this man is handcuffed to the
steering wheel uh three this man looks
as if he has been uh beaten the [ __ ] out
of uh four he has a piece of wire around
his throat and is clearly already dead
so obviously uh this is a murder
now while uh tom the dad is trying to
like process this and trying to you know
get out of the water before the car like
sucks him under the bottom of the lake
as well uh his son corey who is still in
the truck or near the truck thinks he
sees a dark figure like kind of a
shadowed figure over in the woods like
watching
so you're led to assume maybe this is
somebody that had something to do with
murdering whoever the hell this was
now later on you know as tom gets out
and he's drying off and everything and
he's very very traumatized by this
because you know he grew up in a really
small town this is a very safe place
and
you know even though he said he'd seen
dead people before he'd seen terrible
things before but for some reason he
said this really affected him more than
anything else because it was just the
cold-bloodedness of it was what really
got to him somebody obviously tortured
this man and just the meticulousness of
him being tortured in that particular
way and then the fact that somebody
would like take all the time to to put
him in the car so he couldn't get out
like when he was already dead like put
his body at the bottom of the lake and
it also disturbs him because he's like
well whoever did this has to be from
around here because otherwise how would
they know that this lake was deep enough
to hide the entire car and that you know
and that it's so deep that it would
never be dredged and that the body would
never be found i believe they mentioned
at some point that the lake might be
like 300 feet deep or more so he's like
so it has to be somebody around here so
this like really traumatizes him not
only that the murder was so calculated
but also that whoever did it
must live in their town and so it's
probably somebody that they know and
that really really bothers him and over
the course of the book he gets more and
more traumatized by it and kind of
starts you know he starts losing weight
he starts losing sleep he starts having
nightmares that he thinks the guy is
like calling to him and all this other
kind of stuff so that's like another
thing that runs through
now corey he actually goes over to where
he thought he saw the shadow he's not
entirely sure that he saw somebody
standing over he's pretty sure
but he's willing to admit well maybe it
was just my imagination but then he goes
over there to where he thought he saw
the shadow standing and he finds a very
very small emerald green feather now he
doesn't know if this has anything to do
with the person that murdered whoever
this was in the car but he takes it home
with him although he doesn't tell
anybody about it he has his own reasons
why he doesn't tell anybody about it he
doesn't really think anyone will believe
him or he's he's not entirely sure that
he saw anybody and he doesn't want to
put people on the wrong track
so obviously they report this to the
police
and the police investigate and
interestingly uh the guy
um who was in the car like the dead man
that was in the car uh nobody knew who
he was now the only distinguishing mark
uh that they had was he had this tattoo
like on the back of his shoulder that
was like a skull with wings coming out
of it and so the dad describes it and
they pretty much question everybody in
town like nobody knows the dude and
they're like well obviously the lake is
way too deep we can't and you said he
was already dead um you know we can't
dredge him we can't get him out of there
so if we don't know who he is we don't
really know you know he's not from
around here and we don't really know you
know we didn't nobody saw him come in on
a bus nobody saw who he was so it's like
so there's not really a lot we can do so
like the sheriff is still kind of trying
to work on it but he's like look it's
probably not gonna go anywhere because
we have no idea who this dude is so we
don't know where to start like we don't
know who who it was it would have killed
him so that's kind of like the opening
uh you know salvo i guess and this is
the murder mystery that as i said is
sort of like ties all the way through
like who is this man at the bottom of
the lake who killed him why did they
kill him why was he tortured you know
did he have some kind of information or
something like that so from that opening
you know the murder mystery aspect does
keep coming up and a lot of things that
happen over the course of the book like
tie into it later on
but from that point it sort of goes more
into
corey just kind of like
living his life like the murder mystery
is always like he's always kind of
thinking about it like it's always like
in the back of his mind and every now
and then he'll you know go investigate
like a you know an aspect of it like to
see if his hunches are correct or
whatever um but mostly from this point
on as i said it goes into a series of
sort of interconnected vignettes about
you know him and his friends doing
various things around the town so you
know it goes on through their summer
like what they do during the summer and
things like that now some of the
interconnected stories like i said are
are happy like you know when they all
get out for summer and they're all
having a thing where they're running
around in the woods and suddenly they
all sprout wings so like i said it's
like magical realism and
the the trope of it the reason why it
works i think is because one the story
is very very grounded in reality you
have these magical things that turn up
every now and then um you know for
example
uh one time corey is in the car with his
dad and looks behind them and he sees
this black car with flames on it and he
knows that that car is not really there
because that car was a very famous car
around the town that uh crashed and
burned like a year prior and the you
know the guy that was driving it
was killed so he knew it was like a
ghost car so it's like that kind of
stuff but it works because i guess the
conceit of the book is that cory is now
a grown man and is writing down his
recollections
of his of this particular year of his
childhood when he was 12 years old and
because his whole thesis is you know as
an adult you have to hold on to the
magic that you had when you were a kid
like your imagination because he
ended up becoming a writer which is
and when he was 12 that was like the
year that he discovered that that's what
he wanted to be he wanted to be a
storyteller then he's essentially
telling his memories
the way
they felt to him rather than
maybe the way that they really happened
so
so as i said it's kind of like it's very
realistic it's very realistic and then
once it gets into a thing where you know
all him and his friends all get out for
summer and they're all running around
with their dogs in the woods and they
all sprout wings and start flying
around i mean obviously that's
metaphorical it didn't really happen
but
that's he's just writing it the way that
he wanted it to be or the way it felt to
him rather than the way it really was so
that's kind of how because i did see one
review where she's just like yeah as
soon as like they stir spread it wings
and started flying i was just like yeah
no thanks but as i said it didn't really
happen that way if you want to say it
like that it was just that's he's
writing about how like how he felt at
the time so and so as it goes on you
have this whole town and all kind of all
of these sprawling characters you have
vignettes about as i said summer you
have one about like the carnival coming
to town and there being this mysterious
uh trailer that has this monster in it
and it's like they you know nobody wants
to go in but then they have they all
have to go in because they think it's
gonna be this thing and and it ends up
being like essentially a dinosaur maybe
um that gets out so there's that there's
kind of um
this whole
through line because you know this is
alabama in the south so you have like
the main town of zephyr uh which is kind
of like you have your middle class
people and then you have like the upper
class you know the people that own the
whole town and they have a big mansion
and then you have you know the black
area of town which is called britain and
over there
they have this uh woman she's like the
matriarch or like kind of
sort of the boss of brewton i guess just
and she's just called the lady and she's
like 106 or something and every year
they all um they come out to the lake
the tecumseh river and put all this meat
in there and it's for
old moses which is essentially a sea
monster i mean i'm guessing the way it's
described because cory does actually see
it later on when there's a flood in the
town i'm i'm assuming that it's just
like a monster monster alligator but the
way they described it's almost like a
mythical
like a mythical sea monster type of
thing and as i said there's there's also
a um
kind of a thing where
the town there's like a really bad storm
and like the town starts to flood
and cory and his parents they go down to
brewton to help you know stay stave off
the flood waters you know putting up
sandbags and a lot of the houses get
inundated with water
and he and corey ends up
uh having a confrontation
with old moses this big like sea monster
alligator whatever and uh saving another
little a little black boy from it and
from that like he kind of becomes uh you
know the lady summons him and you know
asks him you know thank you for saving
him and thank you for helping us with
the flood and everything and it's like
what what would you like more than
anything in the world and he tells her
that he wants a new bike because his
bike just broke and you know his parents
can't afford to buy him a new one so he
ends up getting this bike which he calls
rocket which you're kind of led to
believe sort of maybe has magical powers
because like i said the um the lady also
kind of has magical powers because some
stuff that happens later on like during
for example like there's a shootout
later on and some stuff that happens in
there like leads you to believe that she
can act that she can actually do magic
[ __ ] um so like i said so it's kind of
that kind of thing but
if it makes any sense
it's more like
it it's more like a mostly grounded and
reality story with just like touches of
magical realism in it it's not like full
bl full bore
you know it's mostly realistic but then
it's just kind of like these little
things happen that
you know that are maybe like magical you
know what i'm saying so i really liked
that tone of it and as i said it just
gave me like a real bradbury type of
vibe so if you're like if you like that
kind of stuff then you'll probably
really be into this if you haven't read
it as i said it's not really you know
obviously i don't want to spoil the the
murder mystery because that actually
does end up getting solved at the end
but along the way
um you know there's all kind of uh
troubles with there's like a gang of
uh moonshiners bootleggers that sort of
live out in the woods and um you know
they you know corey comes across them
like him and his little friends are out
camping
and uh they accidentally sort of like
stumble into
some bad [ __ ] they're gonna do and they
have to like try and thwart that or try
to get away from that like without
getting shot or whatever they have to uh
elude these two bullies that are in the
town that are always like kicking the
[ __ ] out of them uh corey has to go
through some like really sad things like
um
with there's a really if if you're real
sensitive about like animal stuff
um there's a really really sad chapter
in this about uh corey's dog
um it's pretty upsetting so yeah i'm
just i'm just warning you like right
right away it's like you know what i
mean so yeah but it the the point of it
is that
uh he learned how
to
let go i guess of something that he
loved because you know the the dog was
suffering and he he was selfish and he
wanted the dog to stay with him and it
ended up like working out really badly
and he felt really bad so it was that
kind of thing so he has to deal with
like loss
uh and and things like that and finding
out
how as magical and beautiful
as his childhood is and how
it's kind of like about a loss of
innocence too because like some of the
stuff that happens in the town some of
the stuff he finds out about the people
in the town that he thought were good
people uh but were absolutely not good
people it really like caused him to grow
up so it was
so it's really like kind of instructive
i guess that he's that's set when he's
12 years old so it's almost kind of like
he's on the cusp of being a teenager and
growing up and losing that childhood
innocence so it's all kind of tied in
with that sort of theme
but yeah i mean if you haven't read
this uh or if you've read some other
mcammon and haven't got around to this
one because it's not a horror novel uh i
would definitely recommend it and
honestly um i would really recommend
this to
anybody like whatever genre you like uh
because it's beautifully written and
it's really i mean just the themes of it
even if you didn't grow up as a kid in
the 60s i think the themes of it will
resonate uh with everybody because
there's something in in there that
everybody can relate to like from their
own childhood um and obviously you know
if you grew up like in in the american
south in the 1960s then it will resonate
all the harder because of you know the
larger cultural forces at play but you
don't have to have like i said i didn't
grow up in the 60s i grew up in the 70s
and 80s uh but i could totally
you know relate to a lot of the stuff in
here of feeling the way that the kids in
this felt um you know of having to learn
to deal with like really shitty stuff
finding out uh you know that that people
in the town that you thought you liked
or thought you were your friends were
terrible people or you know conversely
finding out that somebody that you
didn't really think that much of
actually did turn out being like heroic
or everybody had something to offer or
something like that so it's just like a
real it's just this really nice uh
tapestry i guess like of a year in the
life of a of a boy but it's also like a
universal type of story as i said it's
got scary stuff in it honestly it's
i think
a kid that was
maybe 12 years old around the same age
as the protagonist in this they might
get a lot of out of this as well it does
have some scary stuff in it but you know
and obviously since it's set in the 60s
there's a lot of uh you know
slurs that we wouldn't use today um but
you know what i'm saying but that was of
the time so it's so that's why it's in
there and um so and i think it's kind of
important to leave it in there so you
know to get like a realistic view of the
time uh that this took place in so uh i
don't really think that i would have any
reservations about letting a kid this
you know 12 or 13 years old read this
and maybe
you know i think they would probably dig
it so so like i said it's not it's not a
children's book it's not a why a novel
it's for adults but i think that you
know tweens could probably get a lot out
of it too and maybe could relate to it
much harder than an adult could i don't
know it does have kind of like a flavor
of nostalgia to it too so maybe that
would resonate more with an older person
but yeah if you haven't read it um and
you've just read or you've just read
some of his horror stuff definitely read
it it's a great great novel um and it's
just i was really really happy to get to
read it again because i think i liked it
even better the second time i i didn't
remember a lot about it like from the
first time i read i just remember like
the feeling it gave me like i really
really dug it like a lot i was like oh
man i really need to you know i i just
remember closing and being like oh that
was like almost like he didn't want it
to end even though
you know like i said it goes off on all
these kind of like tangents and all
these kind of like interconnected
stories but it was still you got so into
you got so into corey's mindset and you
got so into like all the eccentricities
of all these people in the town and all
this stuff that was going on that you
almost didn't want it to end like you
kind of and i mean the way that mccammon
writes is just so descriptive
and his characterizations are so
uh are so sharp that these all seemed
like real people i mean this seemed like
a living breathing
town with all of these people in it and
so you know so it's a really like
immersive experience so if any of you
guys have read it
uh let me know what you think about it
if you haven't read it uh i would
definitely recommend it as i said you
don't need to be into horror it's not
even really that much of a horror novel
it's just kind of a literary fiction
murder mystery type thing uh southern
gothic as i said uh with some magical
realism in it so if that sounds like
something you'd like if you know if you
like bradbury if you like some of
stephen king stuff you'd probably really
like this as well so uh give it a read
and tell me what you think about it in
the comments and i will see you guys on
the next tomes of terror bye